losing a child is not the order of life
but it's a harsh reality for so many
families gabby foster among them jalen
never got to take his first breath but
foster says losing him at six and a half
months pregnant was unfathomable we may
not have got to grow up with them but
there are babies
they matter
she says that's why she and her husband
created jalen's gift foundation so other
families wouldn't feel alone my son he
may not be here but he's helping he's
making a difference through grief
support care packages and even
remembrance photos this box will never
replace your baby but you don't walk out
empty-handed you have something of all
your precious babies memories in here
it's so important for everyone out there
to know that this is something that
happens it happens a lot and it's so
painful
to the people that it happens dr joseph
attishak is the co-owner of desert
perinatal associates one out of four who
actually make it to our office for their
first ultrasound one out of four times
we don't see a heartbeat he says almost
all the time there's nothing a woman
could have done differently and it's
okay to talk about laws i think people
just don't even know what to say to
someone foster says the best thing you
can do for someone who is grieving is to
reach out and help the family say the
baby's name
you know don't be scared to not talk
about their baby
you